greets everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel where today I'm finally ready
to actually finish the Legend of Zelda
of breath of the wild on the Nintendo
switch I got this on Friday at around 5
p.m. it's now around 1 a.m. when she say
morning and in that amount of time I
have put 40 to 50 hours into this game
so the past three nights in a row I go
to bed at 4 a.m. I'm running on like
three four hours sleep every night I am
exhausted does a reason for all of this
madness
so this switch unit belongs to the
company that I work for I was given it
because I'm reviewing three switch games
but now that I'm done playing those I
actually have to give the switch away I
stupidly thought it sells on Friday and
then just got really invested in it
really quickly and as soon as I realized
that I was like oh I have to finish this
before I have to pause the switch off to
someone else or I'm going to just have
to stop playing it but this will lose my
save file maybe not be able to play it
again for a few weeks which would suck
when I'm so far through the story the
last thing that I have to do right now
is go and fight climbed again in' and i
am crazy crazy tired but also crazy
excited so i thought that i would record
my reaction to whatever happens at the
end i'm not going to play audio i'm
going to play through headphones that is
absolutely no spoilers but I am a bowl
of excitement and tiredness and I think
that I probably who react to this pretty
strongly all right guys this mask does
not see me I am just about to walk into
the room where the game should end I
think wow holy [ __ ] okay
I don't even know what taught all this
by it Wow
oh this is scary I don't like this at
all okay sorry
let's guess that's good that's good
oh maybe it's bad no he got angry oh
it's bad shhh pixel he Wow he's very mad
now I've eaten all my hot boil in thank
God I have some sauteed nuts well I know
I am one hot and no food list hot it's
going to work I don't know no no no a
little further away would be great thank
you
two more hits and then this fight is
over hopefully I think I'm super super
super close to finishing this is like to
die oh yes yes yes yes yes come on come
on come on come on okay
oh man [ __ ] get it that's my fan but
that's what The Legend of Zelda breath
of the wild holy [ __ ]
q credits roll what a [ __ ] amazing
game I'm satisfied whining I am
absolutely going to continue playing
this and do some of the stuff that I see
on the open world that I didn't do I'm
so [ __ ] tired also incredibly happy
that I finally finish this game
alright so obviously I have to be up for
work in a few hours and I have not had
much sleep of the past four days but
this is a really weird video that so I
[ __ ] did it you guys I beat to legend
of zelda breath the while the game i've
been excited about for Ella and I
absolutely adored it but also sad that
it's gone like consumed all of my time
puffs 4/5 days it's done got this